coucou comment ça va comment vous
derrière votre écran est ce que tout va
bien pour vous j'espère que vous allez
bien et que tout va bien aujourd'hui on
se parle d'un smartphone dont je vous ai
pas parlé à l'autre jour c'est le poko
x4 j'étais alors le blog je vous en ai
parlé en vous le présente en face à son
petit frère lepoko f4 l'idée c'était
vraiment de savoir et bien parmi ces
deux smartphones lequel pouvait vraiment
être fait pour vous que l'idée de
comparatifs de présentation aujourd'hui
on va aller un peu plus en détail au
niveau du coco x 4 gt qui va être un
smartphone avec beaucoup de performance
qui va avoir un taux de rafraîchissement
de 144 herbe bref une bête très
intéressante donc si vous vous posez la
question à savoir quel smartphone
choisir entre le x 4 g/t et le f4 je
vous renvoie à ma précédente vidéo si
toutefois vous voulez aller loin tout
savoir sur ce disque adjété vous êtes au
bon endroit resté que vous allez voir
c'est super intéressant pour comme a dit
tiens monsieur greuet ce que tu voudrais
pas nous tester le poke au x 4 gt nous
dire ce que tu en penses vas-y de fond
en comble rentrer dans le sujet on y va
donc c'est donc aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec coco
pour vous parler de ce poko x 4 g/t et
vous donner mon retour complet dans ce
smartphone et des choses qui vont très
très bien sur smartphone ya deux choses
qui sont un peu moins bien alors je vous
le redis tout de suite pour qu'on voit
vraiment le tarif le x4 gt on a deux
config 828 8 256 on est à
379 euros sur le 800 28 et on est à 4
129 euros sur le 8 256 giga de stockage
comme ça vous savez tout vole un peu
pour vous donner le tarif tout en
sachant que je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description allez cliquer ce
smartphone vous intéresse il se peut
vous trouver des offres il peut aller
jeter un oeil cliquez on dit là bas
binebine top c'est parti allégis la
génériques
[Musique]
alors poko vous connaissez c'est une
marque dont je vous ai déjà beaucoup
parlé pour cause d'une marque est axée
énormément sur la performance sur le
gaming un tarif extrêmement canon on est
ici sur un smartphone milieu de gamme je
voulais 10 379 429 euros donc ce
smartphone à ce tarif là avec la
performance derrière il faudra faire
plein de jolies choses ya des choses qui
fera un peu moins bien parce que
forcément il faut arbitrer des compromis
on n'est pas sur un smartphone à 1000
1200 euros 900 800 euros donc on en a
pour son argent mais c'est normal donc
qu'est-ce qu'il va bien qu est-ce qui va
pas bien ici sur ce smartphone est ce
qu'on va regarder alors il ya déjà plein
de choses qui vont très bien sur
smartphone à commencer par le design moi
je les aime beaucoup je trouve très
sympa on a un dôme at alors il apprendra
légèrement les traces de doigts mais je
vous invite quand même de toute façon et
je vous dis souvent à venir le protéger
pour éviter les déconvenues ce que
j'aime beaucoup ici secte immense et
design avec ce module photo que je
trouve très sympa comme ça on voit qu'on
a trois capteurs ça fait des semaines
les yeux de chouettes ont été pensés une
chouette avec des espèces de côté un peu
joue un petit nez il manque la le bec
parce que une chouette a pas de bouche
elle a un bec donc ça fait vraiment
penser à ça le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui déverrouille hop là je
vous refais vite fait extrêmement
rapidement que situé sur la tranche on a
un smartphone qui est très cool très
joli design va surtout une petite prise
jack pour venir brancher un casque si
vous souhaitez donc ça c'est très très
cool de l'infrarouge pour utiliser comme
une télécommande d'ailleurs je sais pas
si vous le faites est-ce que vous
utilisez votre smartphone comme une
télécommande ses clients qu'ils le font
ça ne fait pas si vous voulez le faire
vous pouvez le faire vous voilà après
c'est un smartphone est comme ça une
très classique très sympa que je trouve
très efficace pour ma part la boîte
reste également très sommaire on va
passer très très très rapidement là
dedans vous avez votre blog de charge
qui a inclus ces deux-là 67 watts vous
retrouvez votre tiroir de cartes sim qui
l'a gardée au plat vous le prenez alors
regardez venu on se rapproche légèrement
vous avez signe deux écrit ici et vous
avez une sim un donc vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir deux cartes sim donc
si vous en avez besoin usage pro usages
particuliers ou que vous êtes
frontaliers ou que vous avez une double
vie ça vous regarde ça c'est je veux pas
savoir et bien vous pouvez avoir votre
deux cartes sim ici c'est plutôt
pratique et très très bien donc ça c'est
cool donc on est un smartphone qui est
sympa qui est pratique donc déjà d'un
point de vue expérientiel comme ça
design c'est bien le format alors il est
un peu long parce que fatalement on va
être sur un format c'est du passé du
sixième hull 6 pouces donc c'est un peu
grand mais en termes de prise en main on
donc on trouve actuellement au niveau
des smartphones donc ça ne dérange pas
et tout va bien là dessus voilà pour ce
que je voulais vous montrer sur ce
smartphone là dessus d'un point de vue
design ça fonctionnera maintenant il ya
vraiment trois points essentiels à
connaître ce smartphone qui sont
vraiment intéressants le premier point
ça va être toute la partie gaming c'est
vraiment le coeur de métier poko 1 le
gaming sur smartphone vous allez voir
que l'expérience ici et quand même bien
et très complète donc ça c'est cool le
deuxième point c'est ce qui va être
divertissement plus série visionnage
film regarder du contenu de son
smartphone parce que vous avez un grand
écran donc ça on va regarder aussi dans
quelques instants dans ce côté-là
j'inclus aussi les réseaux sociaux parce
que comme vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement très élevé vous allez
voir que ça porte de la fluidité
notamment lorsque vous allez dire
scrollé sur des installé à mes
compagnons ça c'est cool et puis le
troisième point c'est surtout qu'il est
abordable pas très cher avec de la 5g et
ça c'est chouette alors on a tout de
suite commencé par côté gainey dans le
côté game il ya plusieurs choses à venir
voir déjà on va parler un peu de
l'expérience logiciel de peau qu on est
ici sur android c'est me why 13013 pour
pau causé un poco launcher donc on va
retrouver toute l'expérience de poko ici
qui fonctionne bien pour connaissez
probablement déjà un peu l'expérience de
poko c'est très cool vous allez pouvoir
venir gérer votre batterie de façon
intelligente intelligemment j'arrive
plus à parler mais surtout vous avec
quelques petites options qui sont très
très cool notamment ici au niveau au
plat game turbo c'est un petit jeu mode
jeu en fait dans lequel vous allez venir
retrouver vos jeux qui est assez malin
donc là vous avez vos différents jeux
installés sur votre smartphone voyez
qu'elle pouvait venir jouer vous pouvez
lancer ici vous avez en plus ici
quelques petites options intéressantes
le game turbo que vous venez active et
qui va booster en fait les performances
d'un point de vue software qui va
l'emmener un peu plus loin aurait
quelques petits raccourcis désinstaller
les aussi et ça ok le mode performance
que vous pouvez venir au plat
optimisation du wifi optimisation
tactile optimisé l'audio il ya quelques
petites paramètres lavoyer puis après ça
les paramètres pour vos jeux ça c'est
pour chaque jeu grès pouvant venir
paramétrer sa exemple essayé pour un
peuple j voyez comment est ce que je
veux que mon smartphone réagissent par
rapport à mon jeu alors là je le pouvoir
regarder qualité d'image en eau
fréquence d'image la plus élevée ici et
la performance fréquence d'image en
ondes jusqu'à 144 f donc ça veut dire
que je veux le maximum d'image par
seconde je veux 144 images par secondes
ça me permet d'avoir une optimisation au
niveau de la fluidité au niveau de
l'expérience j'ai longtemps c'est très
cool la qualité d'image on n'est pas au
max mais presque et lapins manse bon on
nie pas complètement après avoir
économisé l'énergie donc gestion de la
performance par contre fréquence d'image
je vais la diminuer je vais quand même
vachement moins haut la qualité d'image
c'est pareil c'est à dire un peu la
sacrifier équilibré je suis à peu près
bon partout haute qualité regardez on
arrive la qualité d'image au top au
niveau du taux de rafraîchissement on
est aussi au top mais la performance de
lyon n'est pas au top et après je peux
venir personnalisé tu peux lire matin je
m en 144 m je veux ma résolution soit en
720p ce serait un peu dommage de
descendre un petit peu soit par défaut
et après voyez sur à quelques petites
options plus haut niveau de la qualité
donc ça c'est vraiment si vous vous êtes
un champion vous y connaissez vachement
bien et vous choisissez après vous
pouvez mettre ce que vous voulez comme
vous voulez après à d'autres paramètres
également ici un mode pro vous voyez on
peut venir personnaliser un peu tout ce
qu'on veut ici au niveau de votre
smartphone au niveau des zones tactiles
petit grands moyens aucun on laisse
comme on veut et puis l'amélioration
aussi visuel original modern efforts
extrêmes à vous de voir ce que vous
préférez vous voyez on va se mettre sur
force soit très très cool et tu apprends
plus restaurer les paramètres par défaut
donc on a beaucoup d'options et y en a
je dirais un peu pour pour tout le monde
au niveau de ces gourous sikhs vous
venez vous réveillez ici et redescend et
ça c'est ce que vous avez mis sur table
j si vous voulez d'autres paramètres sur
asphalte vous pouvez mettre d'autres
paramètres sur asphalte donc ça c'est
vraiment déjà une expérience pure comme
ça au niveau du gaming hop là je sors
ici je vais avoir d'autres paramètres
qui sont super intéressante petit mode
juste en bas ça c'est un vote pour venir
optimiser mon smartphone d'un point de
vue logiciel il me l'analyse je vois ce
qui va je vois ce qui va pas je peux
venir nettoyer car dès l'âge un truc en
rouge augmenter la vitesse donc là je
peux venir vider de la mémoire ce
qu'elle permet de venir gagner pour
optimiser en fait c'est tout petit chat
si vous les mises bout-à-bout permet de
venir optimiser mon smartphone je vais
venir libérer du cash dont j'ai un peu
de cash n'est pas énormément de prix ici
et voyez up l'a amélioré tac voilà donc
ça c'est cool et j'ai plein de petites
choses que je peux dire faire ici
directement au niveau de mon smartphone
pour venir l'optimiser donc ça c'est
l'expérience poko alors après ya deux
choses qui est vachement intéressant à
venir connaître c'est que j'ai un tiroir
d'application alors vous connaissez des
du tiroir d'applications toutes vos sap
sont classés par ordre alphabétique vais
pouvoir retrouver la voa préférez vous
la retrouvez en haut est ici elles sont
classées par aux communications dit
artix mans photographie outils nouvelle
lecture les achats les jeux le mode de
vie connaissance éducation finances a
fait donc ça déjà c'est pas mal
maintenant il ya un autre qu'on pourrait
venir vous activez directement et moi je
l'aimé c'est tenir les maîtres par
couleur alors le truc qui est un peu
bizarre mais qu'est-ce que je m'en fiche
devenir les maîtres par couleur m'a par
exemple je dis ben tiens je veux ce
match at je sais que snapshot par
exemple c'est jaune donc je clic clac
sur le jaune j'ai mes applis jeunes y
retrouve la tchatche snapshot c'est dur
à dire assez facilement twitter par
exemple c'est en bleu tac twitter alors
là j'en ai un peu plus donc là je vais
venir chercher twitter twitter twitter
où est mon twitter je le vois pas il est
là où voilà j'ai mon twitter alors par
exemple twitch je sais que twitchell du
violet ce qu'il a sur violet d'un voyage
et que tweetie donc ça c'est un truc
aussi qui est plutôt pratique et qui me
permet de retrouver mes différentes
applications donc à pas mal de petites
optimisations logiciels qui sont
intéressantes et qui font que les
smartphones de poko c'est pas propre à
celui là mais les smartphones de poko
sont plutôt bien fichu plutôt bien
pensées vont venir optimiser
l'expérience d'un point de vue global ça
c'est le premier point maintenant on va
rentrer un peu plus dans le côté gaming
j'en profite de vous montrer sur poggi
pendant que je en train de sauter à
garder au plat sur le côté vous avez
votre mode avec vos différentes options
niveau au plat du game turbo pourrait
venir vider la mémoire directement dans
votre jeu libéré du stockage enregistrer
directement en faire une capture d'écran
mettre un minuteur si vous le souhaitez
et après vous avez accès à d'autres
applications ici directement sur le côté
donc là c'est ici c'est pratique voyez
hop là j'appuie là ça va booster un peu
la performance tu peut désactiver si je
souhaite bon on va le laisser active et
voilà ensuite je suis dans mon jeu pas
pop up on va se poser ici un peu à
l'arraché donc là je me suis mis en
sprint continue alors le truc qui est
intéressant ici c'est qu'en fonction des
jeux auxquels vous allez jouer pas tout
ça mais en fonction des jeux auxquels
vous avez joué vous allez pouvoir monter
jusqu'en 144 hertz le smartphone le
choisira de façon intelligemment pour
vous 60 à 10 120 144 ça dépendra
totalement de votre jeu donc ce que je
trouve moi déjà intéressant ici si vous
voulez c'est que sans même vous prendre
la tête vous allez avoir le maximum de
fluidité qu'il est disponible à un
instant t sur votre je pense à ces trucs
est plutôt cool donc on a un jeu qui est
quand même fluide un smartphone qui est
performant qui est parfaitement pourquoi
parce que vous avez le dit man city 1105
g2 médiathèque alors on va rentrer très
très très rapidement dans le détail pour
vous expliquer c'est un processeur qui a
été gravée par tsmc tn 5 cc le champion
du gravage c'est ceux qui ont font
partie de ce tout cas qu'ils ont une
meilleure technologie de gravage ça une
puce qui est gravée en 50 nanomètres
c'est de récupérer une arme pour pas me
faire flinguer très rapidement et pour
tout vous dire et vous donner même un
petit peu d'informations qui pourraient
être super cool up la connaître tsmc par
exemple c'est eux qui ont gravé la
dernière plus de qualcomm le snapdragon
c'est le 8 jane one mais c'est le modèle
plus parce que le modèle d'avant le 8
génois n'était pas le modèle plus été
gravées par samsung et le problème qu'il
avait celui là si vous voulez c'est
qu'il chauffait un petit peu trop tandis
que la version de tsmc sur le modèle
plus d'un an déjà il ya un peu plus
performant et compagnie ça c'est le
cahier des charges de qualcomm qui l'a
fait qu'il n'a voulu et bien sûr tout le
truc est vachement intéressant c'est que
ici on n'a plus ce problème de chauffe
et notamment grâce au savoir-faire de
tsmc donc ici on est gravé par tsmc qui
est taiwan et je vous le dis une fois de
plus donc on a vraiment une puce qui est
intéressante alors séduit médiathèque
mais on est dans le haut de gamme de
chez mediatek ça marche bien et pour
venir faire tourner je dirais tous vos
jeux vous avez quelque chose qui
conviendra très bien en plus ce qui est
intéressant c'est que si je vous dis
vous avez 8 gigas de ram c'est de la
lpddr2 cinq ans vous dire vous avez ce
qu'ils font aux tables de technologie
drame il vous avez soit 128 soyeux 256
en termes de stockage et seief est 3.1
donc on a vraiment tout ce qu'ils font
en termes de performances on a un très
bon processeur on a une techno drame qui
rateraient bien on a une techno du
stockage qui rateraient très bien donc
pour venir vous amuser vous avez quelque
chose qui conviendra parfaitement bien
en plus de l'optimisation logicielle ici
de poko autant vous dire que à un peu
moins de 400 euros voire un tout petit
peu plus de 400 euros vous avez un
smartphone qui pour le gaming va être
quand même super cool oui je lance
asphalte neuf films elle marque la game
turbo augmenté avec succès et c'est un
jeu très intéressant c'est quelles que
soient les jeux auxquels vous allez
jouer vous allez avoir un smartphone qui
va répondre et qui ira très bien donc ça
c'est quand même vachement cool même sur
1 h 29 pas su si ça tourne ça marche on
se marre bien après il ya un truc à
connaître ici c'est toute l'expérience
audio à l'est les pouces le sont en fait
lorsque je le pousse à fond chez carmen
buisson c'est très très fort alors
bouazzi revanche un casque et ça je vous
le dis tout en sachant que votre haut
parleurs principal c'est celui que vous
ayez trouvé là là ça en temps à leur
confort qu'ils rajoutent heures
l'expérience vous avez quand même aussi
du doigt le bihac mosquée venir quand
même augmenter un peu l'expérience vous
apporter un peu plus de spécialisation
après on chassait smartphones certains
des clients et de nos îles et safran
cassé c'est plutôt cool donc voilà il
faut être plus pour l'expérience gagnée
ici on a un smartphone qui est très bien
qui est exigeant qui est complet et qui
vous permettra de faire à peu près tout
ce que vous voulez et voilà et je
termine à dos donc ça c'est le premier
point toute la partie gaming est
extrêmement intéressante maintenant
deuxième point qui est aussi intéressant
c'est la partie divertissement pourquoi
parce que vous avez comme je vous le
disais un très grand écran de 6,6 pousse
ici les 144 r on s'en fiche un petit peu
pour regarder des films des séries parce
qu'on sera pas en 144 hertz donc on
verra aussi économiser la batterie donc
c'est plutôt intéressant enfin on va pas
en consommer autant en tout cas que si
on montant de 144 heures c'est plutôt ça
l'idée vous êtes ici sur une résolution
full hd plus et vous avez un milliard de
couleurs donc pour venir regarder du
contenu sur netflix nay canal disney +
prime vidéo tout ce que vous voulez y
motors tv compagnie vous un truc qui
très très cool rd je vais vous mettre
pour vous montrer un petit secret alors
là je viens leçon pour tous pas le faire
allumer au niveau des droits mais on a
un écran qui est bonne qualité alors
attention ici on est sur du lcd on n'est
pas sûr de l'amoled comme sur le f4 le
f4 c'est de la mauvaise la grosse
différence que vous allez avoir à peu
près si vous voulez c'est que sur un
écran amoled un pixel noire implique
c'est l'état dont on aura donc ce qu'on
appelle des noirs profonds parce que
quand c'est noir quand c'est un seynois
revoilà pas de photos tandis que la
sueur du lcd sur le x4 j'étais le noir
c'est pas l'aide qui est éteinte donc ça
sera pas aussi profonds mais ça ira très
bien donc on a un écran qui est aussi
hyper bien pour me regardait des films
des séries pour venir vous amuser sous
les côtes est vrai c'est plutôt cool et
quand on parle de divertissement on va
parler aussi notamment des réseaux
sociaux va parler d'instagram on va
aller dans communication se retrouveront
instagram on instagram là et là le truc
qui coulait le 144 hertz alors faut que
sa charge les pages mais c'est que ça
apporte vraiment de la fluidité donc là
on a un truc qui est extrêmement fluide
donc on a vraiment de quoi venir se
marrer et ça c'est plutôt bien aussi une
fois plus pour l'expérience et c'est là
où se sent 44 r c'est intéressant si
vous voulez c'est que il ya un côté qui
va être beaucoup plus confort pour votre
oeil que si vous étiez sur lui 60 hertz
classique l'autre point dont je vous ai
parlé c'est cette grosse batterie de
5040 milliers en terreur qui est à
l'intérieur de smartphone qui vous
permet de pousser autonomie jusqu'à deux
jours attention attention attention
attention si vous jouez à des jeux et si
vous passez beaucoup de temps sur votre
écran vous n'irez pas jusqu'à deux jours
mais sur un usage modéré vous irait
jusqu'à deux jours un jour et demi on va
se dire tout en sachant que et c'est
vraiment tout est aussi très rassurant
est intéressant et je voulais tout à
l'heure vous avez de la recharge 67 soit
donc lorsque vous commencez arrivé un
petit peu en bout de souffle vous le
branchez ne serait-ce que en un quart
d'heure vous allez récupérer quelques
bonnes heures et vous êtes tranquille
donc ça c'est cool et point qui est
positif également c'est que le bloc de
charge est inclus directement dans la
boîte a besoin de l'acheter en plus
quand on voit ce smartphone on se dit il
est très très bon dans plein de domaines
où est ce que le bât blesse un petit peu
et bien le bât blesse un petit plus au
niveau de la photo au niveau de la photo
vous avez trois capteurs je vous dis
dans ma vidéo d'avant vous avez un grand
temps que 64 mégapixels vous avez un
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et
vous avez un capteur accros de 2
mégapixels ok ok ok alors le rendu ça
donne quoi et bien le rendu c'est pas le
truc le plus fort au niveau de poko je
vous donc le grand-angle c'est sûr
saturé c'est pas très bien fait c'est
pas très beau c'est ce qu'on va
retrouver un peu tout au long des
différentes photos sur l'ultra grand
temps que paraissait très sursaturé on a
un très gros problème au niveau des
hauts niveaux de lumière ça marche pas
on le voit là on peut venir nous sommes
un petit peu mais voyez on peut se
rapprocher mais on va pas le faire ça
c'est un peu classique c'est pas un
smartphone qui va devoir vraiment fait
pour me refaire des des photos on peut
venir faire des photos pareil on a un
capteur macro alors lama chrome si vous
regardez souvent mes vidéos vous savez
que la macro très honnêtement sur les
smartphones c'est pas du tout mon dada
c'est se racheter les capteurs en plus
c'est pour dire j'ai trois capteurs mais
ça sert pas à grand-chose gros défauts
qu'on va voir principalement ici
effectivement c'est cette gestion des
hautes lumières qui est pas très bonne
rendu qui pas très naturel qui est
sursaturé et qui dans l'ensemble vous
permet pas d'avoir un rendu qualitatif
au niveau des photos il ya un truc qui
est pas très beau très honnêtement ça
fonctionne pas sur la caméra de cette
fille c'est pareil regardez j'ai un
teint terne c'est lycée voilà donc on
passe très rapidement et lorsque je
viens en condition de pénombre et de
nuit et bien résultat n'est pas mieux
voilà la colorimétrie en plus tire un
peu sur le viol et même beaucoup sur le
violet et on manque vraiment de
précision voilà donc c'est pas du tout
un smartphone que je peux venir vous
recommander en termes de photos on peut
sortir des choses sur le capteur
principal mais faut pas être très
regardant donc si on prend un peu
l'histoire qu'est ce qu'ils me racontent
ce poko x 4 g/t et bien il me raconte
que si vous cherchez un smartphone pour
venir jouer si vous cherchez un
smartphone pour du gaming si vous voulez
de la performance un tarif hyper canon
je voudrais dire une fois de plus
version 828 379 euros 8 256 429 euros et
bien vous avez un super smartphone qui
va être très bien pour la performance
pour venir jouer à des jeux pour
l'emmener partout avec soi c'est aussi
un smartphone qui est hyper canon avec
de la 5g ses écrits et si noir sur blanc
donc ça c'est cool on a une puce qui est
performante on a une grosse batterie on
a de la recharge rapide on a une très
bonne expérience au niveau gaming on a
une bonne expérience logiciel keira bien
on a un outil fonctionne bien donc on un
smartphone qui est cool qui par contre
n'est pas très bon en photo alors vous
parle même pas de la vidéo voilà un peu
donc si vous voulez acheter ce que poko
sait faire ce que pour qu'au fait le
mieux c'est dire la performance à des
tarifs hyper canon vous avez en tout et
très cool ici et surtout c'est un des
rares smartphones sur le marché à
proposer un taux de rafraîchissement de
144 à hertz donc on va questions via
vraiment ciblé les gamer avec un grand
écran avec un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile je voulais pas dit là on est à
combien on à 270 en conviendra aussi
parfaitement bien donc monsieur et
madame les gamer et bien vous avez au
meda madame monsieur les gays mais pas
dans ce sens là vous avez un smartphone
qui est très cool et en plus à 80 euros
de réduction en ce moment son téléphone
sur le site de poko et amazon je vous
mets lien en bas dans la description a
vous de me dire ce smartphone pourrait
vous intéresser puis une fois de plus si
vous avez un doute par rapport au pos
coeff 4 vous savez pas sur lequel allait
et bien ma vidéo disponible sur ma
chaîne youtube allez jeter un coup
d'oeil pour venir vous aider à vous
guider dans votre choix en tout cas si
vous voulez celui qu'elle plus haut taux
de rafraîchissement c'est évident c'est
celui là et ça c'est cool et moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire on
se retrouve très vite pour continuer
bien évidemment à part les tec appareils
smartphones mais aussi de plein d'autres
choses ça c'est très cool vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous des bisous d'abord
nous ya bientôt chaos
[Musique]
e